"Hello? Player? Can you hear me? Okay."
"Try changing volume... It's really important that you hear me." Okay... All right.
"One two, one two. Mic check. All set." Hello? "You can hear me now?" Yes. "Hey, did you notice the subtitles?"
"It's actually me typing them as I speak." Wow... "Pretty neat skill, huh?" No.
"Look, I can even type with my eyes closed!" *typing sounds*
"So, how did I do?"
Badly. "Okay, let's continue whenever you are ready."
Okay. All right. I didn't- I haven't even started the game.
Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier, and welcome to 'Dude, Stop.'
Now, this game is a fully released version of a game that I played on Game Jolt a while back by the same name.
Basically the entire objective of the game is to no-Not Do WhAt ThE gUy TELLS YOU TO DO
Basically if you  remember The Stanley Parable, you had free choice there.
Where in this game you have free choice as well, and uh the only way to explain it is to get started...
"Hello there new player!" Hi!
"Thank you for participating in my test." You're welcome!
"Just follow my instructions and all will be fine."
"Um... You can click Start now." What if I don't? "Go on." No!
"You can do it!" I can't!
"Just a click." I ca- I don't even know what a click is!
"Uggh... I'll just click it myself." No. No!
"Okay, read the rules and do not proceed without me, 'cause you're gonna break something." Uh-huh.
"You kids always do."
Wha- okay, I am 28 years old. I am an adult. Okay here we go
Hmm oooh
"8. 9. 5."
Hub bub bub. Hububububub. Hububul!
"What was that?!"
Nothing! "Wha- I looked away for 10 seconds and you already smashed it?!"
"Anyway, what are you even doing here? You were supposed to wait on the previous screen." I-I bet there-
"Fine, I'll draw a new vase. Just don't proceed without me!"
I bet that something would have happened- "I really need to make this call so just- Just sit tight and don't click anything."
"Aaand, a nine. Awesome."  *phone call sound*
Okay, so what happens if I actually wait?
Pfffffffffff
How long am I supposed to wait? Do I have to go play another game before I'm able to continue?
Aight whatever I'm bored. I have A.D.D. I can't stand here forever.
"Hi! Hello! I found a new tester for us..."
"Yeah, sitting there, doing... his best". His best that's me. This is sexual. Something like sexual. Probably not- no if I'm getting sexualness from a book.
"Hm. You there?"
Mmm... dop
"Wait a second, did the player just..."
"No-no, it's all good. So, about that bet - shall we do it with this tester?"
"Yeah, I still think this one won't fail..."
"Oh, by the way, you never said what I'll have to do if I lose...aha...yeah..."
"Aha..."
"Wait WHAT?! NO! i'm not doing THAT!"
"I mean, ye-yeah, sure, this tester gonna play nice."
"EVERYBODY DOES."
"But... that's just..."
"Humiliating"
*sigh* "Fine! FINE! I'm-- Stop pushing! I'm in!"
"Oh, let me get back to the player. See ya."
"Ahem, Tester?" Hi!
Hello? I don't know what you were talking about there but- "Player?" Hello? Okay, alright.
"Player?" Yeah, that's me! They call me player. Markiplayer. Ooooohhh...
Put that right there. "Hey! No!"
"I just made a bet that you're gonna be nice, and you already lost on every puzzle so far?!" I didn't even know there was a way to win!
"Like...*sigh*"
I'd play nice if you told me how!
"Okay, let me tell you something. There were 15 people before you and they all did well"
"15! Don't you dare be some sort of a special snowflake and ruin the game for me!" That's me, I'm the special snowflake! Hello, I'm here for my special snowflake thing, what is that?
"Speak to me!" Oooo
I don't know what I just got, but I got somethin'
"Are you planning something?" I did it! Did I do it? Is that not it?
Ooh. "Are you planning something?" Eh?
"Nooo! The arrow! It's supposed to-"
*sigh*
"I see how it's going to be! You're not gonna play by the rules, are you? Great. Great!"
"That's what I get for being too trusting! I could have tried to test it all by myself,
but nooo, I needed to invite YOU!" I didn't get invited!
"And I agreed to that stupid bet!"
What was the bet? "Why did I do that?" What kind of sexual deviancy do you have to do?
"I already see how you're gonna ruin everything, laugh at me, and then read a walkthrough online just to find the best way to be the WORST!"
"You're not doing that! Not in my game! You nasty piece of sh-" *dial tone*
Oookay, well there's no need to be that rude! My goodness! With your 'tude!
My dude, you need to get some therapy.
Okay all right game over then.
How about no? "Hm. Wait. Am I too harsh on you?" Yes! "Maybe you just didn't know what to do."
My emotions are hurt. "Or a cat stepped on your keyboard?" That's also true.
"Or there were no good solutions." Uh-huh. "Or it was an accident, you know. Stuff happens."
Yep, I was an accident, my mama told me. "Anyway... I need to punish you. Don't take it personally, it's just..."
"You did bad and I want to discourage you from doing that again." So uh, about that, about the discouragement thing, why would you-
"So?" Ooo! I got a trash cup!
"I feel like it's gonna be a fuuun ride..." Me too man.
You and me, we're gonna be best buds before you even know it. Before you even realize all your mistakes that you've made up until this point.
You're gonna, you and me we're gonna be best buds.
Alright. "Let's put it riiight heeere."
Uh-huh. "And it will stay here forever. Enjoy the view!"
"WHAT? Why are the packs unlocking? That's a bug, don't click. Better go and uuuhhhhh.."
"Watch the credits! Yeah, that'd be nice!" Okay, all right. If you hadn't said anything I wouldn't have known about it
"I won't miss you."
Ah, that's rude. I'm gonna watch the credits.
I'm all about supporting the developers!
Game by Halfbeard, two halves of the beard, two and a half beards, two and a half men-beards. Hello again, I'm here, whoooa
That's a lot of, that's a lot of cups.
Jigsaw pack. Finish the jigsaw puzzle to unlock this. Oooohhh!
Those are the things that I was finding, those are pieces of a jigsaw.
Oh, there's so many choices! Oh, so I get to see it all. Okay, I'll do, I'll do something. I'll be nice! I'll be, I'll be nice.
"Okay, you can touch. But-no bad bad, only good good!" That me! Only good good! "Let's start simple. Should be an easy solution for you."
"You completed a side quest!" NOOO!
Ahhh! "Well, more like a... pointless task." But I saw- "Anyway, here is your cup." Shut up!
"Just so you know, achievements and jigsaw pieces are saved automatically as you collect them."
"So, even if you exit the pack you'll still have them." Great, good to know! Oooo, I want to go back! Oh.
"Ok, the letter was a good start." Alright
*inaudible* sock and sandal "Maybe in your country..." What's wrong with that? What's wrong with socksandal? I missed the jigsaw too.
I'm missing all the jigsaws. "Go on. Give it a little push!"
"I'm so excited!" Yaaaay
...I think?
"FYI: it's not gonna change the ingame font - I removed that feature." I like Calibri.
"Hmm, I'm glad you have at least a smidge of taste." I do, ~I like sans-serif fonts~ "Okay, this is the finish line. Just one more!"
Uh-huh. "No. Film it! That's a photo."
"Which is nice, of course, but you need to *film* it!" Why? I'll do it, but only because you asked me nicely.
"That went better than expected." Okay cool
"Yes! Yessss!"
"That's how you're supposed to play! and for that you deserve a trophy! I've sent it to you by mail, it should arrive shortly..."
"Aaany minute now!" At my house or in the game? "Where is it?" I dunno, you sent it. "So, like..."
"Um..."
"*mouth farting noises*"
"How are you?" Not good! Where's my trophy? "Uhh..."
"Have you played any good games recently? Some casual point-n-click puzzles, maybe, hm?"
*fwoop* "Oh, thank god. Open it!"
Don't know if I want to but here I go. How did you...? IT'S A PENIS!
UGH! "Wait, that's not it. There's something else. Keep going!"
How the frick did you fit that in there?? oh
"That's for my mother-in-law. The next one MUST be your cup." How many penis-like things can you fit in an envelope?! ohh
"Here you go!" Woahh!
I got a Long Cup. That's what they all say *ding*
Ok-goo--uh, great? "You know, I was scared after the first pack but now
Playing, like that you'll have, no problem unlocking the rest of the get wait, why is it still locked it should have
This is weird it is weird or i'm gonna go back in and be an asshole there's your talk puzzle piece right in the corner
yeah, okay
Man i've shown, you the correct spot yeah but i put it there what here but right here
Oh, gosh i don't know. How, letters work, people don't i really have to send letters anymore remember
singing is bad
Singing is not where them ever heard of a butterfly effect. No that's the
Wrong, way, oh, well too bad for you, good thing i'm an asshole
She's a font on his hands it's really
It's not unpopular if anything comic sans is more popular than it's ever been in its life
beauty
Quickly filming, no filming i'm filming it's a photo if i take enough pictures
It'll turn into a movie don't you know. How, movies work, oh?
about upside dune
There we go?
If you look at it upside down then it smiles if you look at it the normal way then it's frowned i want a double
Smile not a double frown, oh?
What is this hmm here's your prize?
see i'm
Timeand your hard work in the pack
Watch closely it's on the left, okay now shuffling shuffling shuffling
where no not this one here this one either here i
Lied it's not a diamond of course it's not a diamond you are ruining my game, why
Would it be a diamond, oh?
It's so funny you should have seen your face freakin, face you have a, face full of punch if you, keep that up
Fuck dude i got a. Tiny cup, for my, tiny dogs anyway
No, not yet let, me unlock you a pack i need, you to pass some tests i'm a
Cure stay here i'm gonna, do things here i know. There's puzzle pieces that i haven't seen
You, didn't pick me i picked you, that's how. Buying games works yeah you got it okay i'll show. You
I don't but i assume i do
did i do
Okay i'm gonna
Be super nice i'm gonna nicest right blam perfectly you got it you got it you got that that's what i'm here for baby
Body, baby, boo i could get nine, well right except for would you suggest the game to your friends
No, not yet anyway
Fuck you that at the end
That's how, you succeed by doing good deeds in a?
Video game yeah it seems, about right that's. Gotta be pretty far in my life
Hey, i did it i think i don't know, what i did but i did it did i get a new cup
Did i do it there we go?
So, what's this one all about go somewhere do something and you will. Certainly get it
Well i don't know what that is song to move on?
Hello, lost cause, born to be dumb
F is for failure goal of education
No, time to explain let's go in and out twenty-second exam okay, before starting let, me tell you a story
and then they died one piggy made a house out of and died
Second piggy stole a bunch of bird eggs and regretted it and then he died the third
Was dead all the time i got em puzzles, well you know, what piggies don't get to play, my game
oh
Man what a coincidence i have a little test right here to see if you are one of them and don't even bother
Asking, me i'm just, gonna judge sadly, from that corner
I have a mental age of seven but i am very
very old
Wiggle waggle wiggle wiggle, oh?
my, god do i deny the truth or do i give him the lie that he's comfortable with i
demand the truth
Which of the following is correct, oh?
i'm just vaccinations really cause autism um
obviously, oh
The truth of the world is controlled by, okay, this is just a fact
Yes it's absolutely, true, okay all right, oh the world is not ruled?
By, lizard, people then how, do you explain the zook see you're
I'm zelda name is for a. Boy or for a girl it's for either who are you to judge
Okay all right so the following is allowed to do if you, were playing with. You didn't. Via social media job one ah
would you believe that illuminati control everything even games
Here your results you failed, no worries you can, still participate in the ceremony
yay
wahoo
whoa
ha
Yeah, ha!
Hello, ho!
And here comes your future take it and all have
number twelve
To, go thank you i'm assuming, you're, saying i'm working at mcdonald's but, uh joke's on you mcdonald tires from within
It's working the test, is working i'm right you're wrong the rest of the game is locked and you are out of here?
Not necessarily i'm gonna go back in again
Shush, shush, your beautiful mouth watch this how old am i oh yeah you got it oh this perfect got it no yeah
Oh, no i guess whatever all right let's see your apple
Girl, whatever
little anything else and
You, did, well you passed the exam congratulations
great job oh
beaters
No i'm not
Any, human, with a shed of common sense should be able to pass this exam so don't get too excited
But good job on being no
Thank you, oh?
It's called a mortarboard cap, i didn't know that
That's thank you you're learning good work thank you keep going
Like this, and we can, win that bet i thought i think i was actually thinking about using the duck on you?
What's the duck or a disaster that would be your target, about the sock we're talking, about the suck you're
gonna, use the suck on me
Twenty-second i'm gonna go again. Oh what were you trying to earn extra points for being fast
Well i forgot to start my stopwatch
Oops, never mind i'll evaluate you now, oh?
Wow, okay all right thank you very much for that asshole
But i did it i did it right did i get it
You're, gonna, make me do it again i'm gonna do it again
Silly, me got the stopwatch, again
Oh, boy all right shut up i'm gone again
Just cuz, you're an, asshole doesn't mean that i'm gonna give up
Okay, okay, fine here you, go and now i'm gonna grade you, okay?
But but, what about what about what, about the star what
About the star for doing it fast i did it fast can i have it
Oh, there, we go that feels good that feels real, good alright pack
Five three puzzle pieces okay all right you've probably seen it in the trailer right and they keep on the internet no
Green means go
Thanks man thank you thank you i feel good about
the concept five pieces one box
Watching you now, i watched 2 girls 1 cup i'm pretty sure i know. How. This goes and then don't go good, oh?
yeah
i hope they
Live too right yeah
Right, why, do you kind of bring in my real, life, above rice shut up right asshole shut up right are you just gonna
right
Hey, shut up god damn, okay meat sack you can clean
Yes, oh i'm the best, oh, oh?
There we go you, happy, with me you, happy i seek your approval, about putting stuff in the boxes
Okay i got this one i know how. It goes this one's looking a bit more war
So one's looking a bit more violent than the other ones i just gotta say right let's shove red, back in here excuse me
Something fun don't
Worry, it'll be possible later in the game i don't like the sound of that i'm only gonna draw penises i know
Myself it's just the way the world works when i'm involved magic, trick i'm gonna, make this line
disappear
It's gone i did it i don't know, what i did but you, did something, amazing i'm real proud of you
Would you choose, well i'm korean sir?
i, do i'm korean
Look, at these smiley faces you wouldn't, want to make them
Sad would you know i have a real real slow. Okay real slow
nailed it
Number seven i thought i was player sixteen was a nice 16, wasn't there 15 people before me wasn't i player 16
Why are you, saying - blaire seventeen now you did it you can be good after all i can
Try i made a trophy for you except that i didn't i ran out of ideas
Copy, the puzzle from before and voila it's your problem now. Okay thank you
Have fun but not too much fun i hope kids could
Be watching was i supposed to mean put that there and then this one's there no?
There got it oh?
That don't look, good that don't look right
Some don't look, right about that uh this one da
Dada, da it's not right, okay am i stupid or something dry, not allowed legos work alright, what if i dis is da?
Weekend we're. Gonna disassemble the whole thing fresh start from scratch we're gonna start kind of an invert
Inverted spire got maximum height from the small bits available
We got threes
Here okay, that's good now that that's there, we could just kind of build up the base a bit and
Voila there, we go it's perfect
Whoa it's some kind of thingamajig i think, we all know what?
That is okay all right thank you having fun i see yes
yes
I don't want to know i gotta do i got do something else
I'm sorry wow that's a little overreaction?
For me pick it bean colorblind you should build a rocket just don't forget to clean up afterwards, okay i built the rocket i think
did i do it i
Mean i built something over there yeah it's a tower. Oh hey, you dropped, what i drop five?
and they all want to slice one for me one for them one for me one for them one for me one for them one
For me one for them got it
pineapples
Okay, that's the one thing where i draw the line, you weirdo i don't want pineapples
Okay all right, well i'm gonna make a, mess when i piss in your bed i'm gonna take a shit in your pillow
See how much you like it
I, did i've really thought, about it
Nothing i'm not that kind of guy i don't want to do nothing i wanna take what
You, say would say
Oops, sorry, about that one oh, what i get you finished all puzzles yeah let, me prepare the stage, okay all right
Ladies and gents yeah
boy
And this person is gonna receive, some special trophy tonight i hope it's the pregnancy. Oh pistol prisoner paintings
Behind the next one is gonna be legend
Terry, damn that, wasn't it looks like, what's the famous
Legend....
Dary!!
Come on, he wasn't here before okay, maybe next one
Yeah, we're very close, okay i'm ready i'm excited i was already excited
Ready?? Look at it, look, look, loo-
I'M LOOKING!!
Aww
I hope I ruined it for you.
that's a damn shame
Oh i'll take it. Can't avoid a spoiler cup!!
Hehehehhehe
yeah i get it. Okay, thank you I mean.
NIIIICE!
Got it i found it! i found it! i found it! Did get him? I got him! okay let's do this i don't know
How to get those no, no what the say cheese seize the cheese right, what do we got here hmm a, story
Found this old educational tape that i really liked as a kid and i thought it would be a nice addition to the game
Okay, you can play
All right i don't know what that means something something cat, when you're in the wrong place at the wrong time i don't know
What that, means why, is the cat. Highlight a, bowl over there squeaky cup. Good toy for a good cat
Okay insert the missing word when cats are, bad fun times are. Had dogs are sad
By the way?
I don't want cake i really don't want cake
on the sink
okay
The cat, wants to leave the kitchen i did it
The cat, wants to leave the kitchen i know. How. This goes i'm real good at. Saying things
That's a fact but you say it that way and it seems, weird?
Water makes cats wet i know that but
That's still not okay all right come on be brave be brave cat, don't get wet you slam your
Ass into it hard enough
water turn off
Always land on their feet, oh oops, oh no wait no jump back up no
i
Should have, oh i want to knock over the carp, yeah
Whatever i'll get in the next time i know i'm gonna have to do it again
on the floor
I don't, want to that's right
Try to use a cat in a sentence a
Cat stole my
Wife oh, what, is that try to use a table?
Now, describe the cat's actions
Situation the cat does the flying grin or dd i haven't said anything
What question, was that what are you talking about read read what aloud and?
we would i didn't, want to i
Didn't want to do that i tried didn't go to a toy, continue to the next
okay
yes yes yes
Because she often still sausages from the refrigerator
Let's say together
Bad doggie, bad tonight you will sleep outside no
no
okay
The dog, went out for a. Walk i knew this the weather's dry
Afternoon, oh, no the earth, is hard the sun is falling fast the sun disappeared the sky, was all clear the dog
Was having a blast
mm-hmm
She, was having the time of her life, he's jumping
Hi, kiss the moon goodbye ma didn't disturb the masters wife what don't kid, why would?
Now please, answer the following. Questions, what's the doggie very good in this fragment hmm very
good
Continue to the last exercise in this lesson
hmm
Page 19. Exercise 7 let's answer, some questions together, hmm doc says
Hey, that's right
I'm frantic, meow at 3 in the morning they're seeing demons
demons ghosts they're seeing demon ghosts possessed
I don't want to know the, answer to that question, why, do you have so many, weird questions about cats. Yeah maybe, okay?
Maybe that's a good thing i don't like, this lesson
I don't want to go, through the lesson, again
Hello, sis took like 20 minutes you sat through the course but it wasn't enough i need
Some actual result i was trying but locos trains a, bad dog
It's not my fault i didn't get
jack
shit on that run-through always sit on tom i didn't do dick i didn't even get all the puzzle pieces here we go i
Don't want to go, again
Who, sticks landed in the shards of glass
Okay, alright thank you i want to can you shut up please
and
Amazing, white cat
let's go to the next
Let's do that yeah let's, do that let's do it let's do it i don't even know, what exercise we're going for some?
English learning exercise or something like that
They're, gonna throw. Puzzle pieces and we will get the weirdest, oh?
Oh, this cat is impervious to glass i just what
your, dumb cheek is the little dumb but there are smart animals i don't, want to i said i
Won't accept it i remember that cake, well forget it performance like that life, has prepared you another gift
From for you from life. Oh life is always, giving me good presents so far what could it be
It's oh that, was gonna be like a dead?
hi
This is not how. Do you do this alright cool all right whatever, oh, oh, yeah?
Cool turn him into grenades
Duck, after all what is the dog, i want to know what the dog?
reckons the english papa for
Uh-huh, yeah i thought so going to finish, my course, okay here, we go i'm gonna do it again
Nice that's, weird but dolph taking don't know. How. You're worming. Your way in there kitty cat but okay?
It's the zoomies she's got the zou bisou, bisou easily
The best dog the best dog, i have better get this cake
too, late cats already gone
dog, says, goodbye we're done thank you cake i see you i
got it
Classic so did you like it yeah
a little long as you can see
Okay, i wasn't lying about not wanting it either
You need to like
Candle it's a candle and there is cake you know, stick it already
whoa
It's lit it also looks like a, big old middle finger to me not, gonna lie it looks like a big fat middle finger huh
something, tells, me maybe that's a little more intentional than you think it would be
Yeah, but they didn't get the last puzzle, paws and i don't want to go through it again
Alright, don't move on, oh it's what he's tricky you, want to be very careful, uh-huh
Surprise language test how, do you pronounce it i pronounce it jeff thank you very much
And you're dead better luck next time, excuse me
Excuse me i don't care, what anybody, says it's pronounced gift, and that's
Just that it doesn't matter that the person, who invented the format says it's pronounced the other way
He's fuckin, wrong, because everybody, decided something else and words are defined by popular demand
Why, does one guys, where's one guy very very i don't care he contains, oh my
poor, no graphic research materials i see i understand
so what
You, were wrong anyway you were an asshole and making me look like an asshole before puzzles
What do i do with this one leave it hanging, why it's got plenty of charge what's got plenty of charge
oh
No enough, no don't be good i'll
okay, you have one
More chance i don't think it's gonna matter at all actually the last one no second chances the duck
was coming all right, okay, whatever you got bring it on
What's the happy apps just a big phone just phone's big phone def phones real big, oh
Hang on i got it i got it i got it do it do something do something i got it hmm
Okay, two photos are more than enough?
Huh, put the phone down
No one needs this much photos of your stupid cats, well okay?
but i wanted to do
i
wanted to do bad
it
Nah, i'm joking it's not like, those crazy, lines for new. Phones
Hmm, okay all right i i know how, to ski excuse me
Excuse me you're doing something wrong good job
You, see people willing to donate that to charity
Same guys and you are in a role of a driver uh-huh
Okay, so what about this already no i don't think so no i don't want to, oh?
I get what i was supposed to do okay i got it okay all right i get it
step crack crack crack
My poor mother's back, mom i'm, sorry i'm sorry
Back and do it properly, no did i done did i didn't mean to get the god i got nothing cuz. I
Blow up, okay i said no no no, no, no more not otech nope, no no no?
No, no i want enough i want more?
I wanna taste your duck. Oh what is what the book i don't taste your duck?
Duck initialise okay i mean it's your fault you know i have to use it on you?
warning
Yeah, yeah i know unstable
activate duck god freakin, yeah, yes
Why is it twitching no no, no don't, ask, me it's your dog
Don't, ask, me i don't know. What's going on here you're doing all this not me
what
About it but found one of those all right, oh my god
They're just as planned. Okay, ducky's activated, and you won't even have a chance to, mess with the game yeah
Well it's not really messing with the game i'm doing it the way
I, want do it if you're just a stupid idiot that can't and allow. The truth works then
All right cool, oh you found a bad solution
Congratulations and now look how, my duck will undo this mmm
it's still bad
No, no no, no let's try, again, same puzzle, okay?
How, do we do the same, oh?
They're, gonna get real pissed at me after i keep trying there's so many times there to the back know
That guys i don't know, what's happening to that guy, there go back
Know your place no i don't think so this, guy's really, giving them a!
What for but i don't think that it's gonna help him i think if anything i think the guy in the douche at
Cana is enjoying it it's probably not
Ideal for the whole situations happening here
excuse me or you can't i probably can, blam-blam-blam-blam
Am i supposed to just let him
know
That duck?
Did you, do that i didn't, do anything duck, yeah it's your dog, control your duck
What are you, gonna sue me let, me double-check something. Uh-huh do cool. You just spelled duck wrong, oh?
Row, boat, oh?
That's that's weird? Oh that's, weird and percentage you seem to be a little off on your duck?
Maybe you were over exaggerating this
Test it try now i'm not a, tester i'm a. Player i'm a. Player, excuse me excuse
No, god damn you duck, why, don't you work you should prevent this stop look
I don't understand just next level, okay, cool, let's see how. This goes oh?
Opening and close close go go go go go go, go
The, bad solution doesn't work now open the door and let him in no
No wait what kind of what got a, weird thing about this game is like suddenly i wanted to disobey you but whatever
Good ina let's move, oh, oh?
Close go, oh?
Duck seems to be messing with me
now
Okay, i'm starting to think the unstable thing is the duck
Uh-huh, you thank you but i am perfectly, stable i'm trying to be consistent you're the, one that's messed me up
Go, go, forget it it's not working let's switch to the next puzzle already i don't even know, that is it i?
Mean i kind of like it too but i'm just trying to be consistent
mmm
Funny, about that
Yep, see i told, ya you did a, bad job as always and this buggy piece of crap, did nothing to prevent it
hmm
Did i win no that didn't last, long, hmm, but yep i'm shutting it down, oh
Put the duck, garbage collector, oh i mean i thought it's gonna stop you but
Apparently it's as broken as you i am very, fine i am not broken
I'm sure you, want to disable
yeah, now carefully, why ii
yes
yes, oh
boy
What happens i i don't see your screen anymore, well it's me you see anything?
Damn it no nothing if you, do
Well this is awkward?
But you'll have to destroy the dock, yourself, why is this my job i know
You, don't like, my life you just do what i tell you and don't, mess with me i like you perfectly
you're, the one that doesn't like, me and we open up the console
please
no
no, no
I guess it's one of those things, where i can't, not do it so let's try it see all the debug buttons no
Buttons, don't touch anything unless i tell you to
Please, don't touch anything i'm gonna touch everything duck options, oh?
Show x4 one color off hello fog of war, oh?
And keep in mind i'm still gonna find out if you click something else feel the view
Oh, let's i play field of view a?
high
so i can get the maximum
Wide range and see when people are sneaking up on me let's get that all the way up to 90
Get a quake, style a, mini skin black and blue white and gold white and goal with
Actual funny jokes yeah, flip, screen, horizontal blur blur negative one really sharpen it up
Microtransactions on or enable all right whatever duck options
Destroy button, uh-huh, okay, well there's only one button
After the loading finishes you will see two buttons, okay?
All right destroy the duck, okay, you see the
blue
come on, oh
Where is the cup, and why, is the duck's icon here, what did you do did you click the wrong button i tried
My best oh my god?
You are just
amazing
Thank, you pray that it's not gonna keep breaking the game now. Okay, oh?
That sounded like it might keep breaking the game but i'm not arms ensure wait so oh?
great
It's a cup
Fantastic cool bug becomes a feature hell, yeah that's what i was always looking forward to anyway, okay all right what
Did they give me one thing out of all this
Okay, that's weird i got all the puzzle pieces though, so that's nice want to try, again
yes
I got it you
Don't pick a side to be good you just do just do it you just do it that's what. You do that's how
You, do it got it
practicing safe yes i am yes i am i like to practice that continuing the technology, theme, uh-huh
Yeah, what i don't even know what that means but i'm assuming that, was just a
Joke, look at the kitty go so graceful quick
Got it i got it
Hawaii, day soon a whatever that i don't know. What kind of moon language that is but yeah it's?
Cute know that standing in line reaches a head is like pre-ordering let's wait together
Just kidding, you're, good, okay, thank you that was a really funny, joke glad you were kidding, about that one you're, still funny man
next up
I like francie i don't hate you you for some reason hate me and i don't get it it doesn't go both
Ways the cracks are lava this is gonna be tricky was it a spoiler
okay
Okay, we got this?
We got this, oh?
yeah, oh
Yeah, oh yeah there we go much kids don't do cracks
Alright, we'll see about that i was about to hate you forever but, hey, you did good
Kinda as much candies as you can catch. Oh, yeah, whoa oooh?
Piece of candy, oh i get that reference that's a funny reference you're really funny
About that on your references or whoa candy cobbler, don't crush it nice shut up
Wait wait wait uh why is it here go back, uh
See, why the duck was there, no, oh it's gone the ducks gonna be a part is for now?
Okay, alright let's see this, oh?
I like this pack i made it so you would have less time to think about how, to ruin it cool
Let's hope, duck, won't get in the way, well you just said that so now
Duck is definitely gonna get in the way i'm pretty, sure it's time so be quick, okay?
They, did okay first puzzled worked, no duck so far
hey
Looks, like you everything's fine yeah died in it oh
okay i guess
Yeah, it's working. Okay, you are actually doing good yeah i am, okay?
All right that's good that's good i guess you didn't screw up completely
By, enabling the duck back there i guess not i still can't understand, why, you click the red, button
Okay, let's see your results. Okay, let's see how, did i do, oh
Could be a better way to end fastback than a race
Oh, win the race get the cup, so get ready to click which one is me which, was me you know, tell me which was?
Your, not tell me which one's me, oh, no, they are winning you're clicking, way too slow
Here i'll help, you oh get ready
That doesn't seem fair at all those are row. You're still too slow
You, gotta, go fast i sonic just take, this sonic the hedghog
Long, way to me
You know what it's my, game swell cheat a little, well nothing else is new, there. Huh, you can't lose now i
Don't really have any control over this, okay just just take it and leave thank you
Oh, each playthrough has different puzzles
oh
I get it now, oh?
Hearts, squeeze, squeeze, squeeze have you done i don't know probably something dude
Don't touch it what oh, sorry i didn't even know, about that everything closed?
Closed i'll punish you later okay, whoo?
Just eat already, no i'm busy
That's a finish let's count your score okay?
There is your reward a?
Golden shoe wow
Be quick if you want what wow? I don't know if i want 100
My it's so easy to trick you, well you just it was but it was once again, why?
Would i give you something good if you, did bad why would you give me something at all, why
Would you give?
Me something at all unless you just like kind of sadistic and kind of just want me to feel bad about it
Hey, you know odor can be a good thing
Good or there's such a thing as good odor and i have that i got it anyway now i gotta like remember
Which puzzles i was good at. And which ones i was bad at? Going up how, about going
down
correct
Okay, it's easy
I'm just trying to do the opposite
responsible storage uh-huh
Scouse, basarat' looks correct, that's irresponsible i didn't i didn't even want you to answer correct i did it
Let's try it again
Whoa, i've seen it all
Make, haste dude let's do it let's do it let's do it paulette. Junk. Junk. Junk junk
Junk, junk, junk
What did i get?
String nothing else i got 11 of 12 and 10 and 12 so i just got to remember i just got am amber
sorry
I think i'm missing just one more i'm thinking i'm missing one for one of them must be right, okay whoa fresh haddock
oh i got them all whoa i did it i
Did it so good what is what is that cops might get damaged, but, we can rebuild it be monster be nice?
Perfecto, only kids from the nineties will understand and audis and all the others basically anyone who knows the rules
Would be nice and hundred percent b monster in arms all right let's do this
Probably not good, oh, oh?
process
Now it is the worst possible time for that
Quick press escape exit now, don't you tap it in your engineering, oh?
No, please don't teach to tuck anything, bats i'm begging you just press escape and exit
What are you doing stop it apple in the bin
Apple in ben rose in banner ruined the whole game you don't know. That you don't you, don't know that
Showed you dare i did it no no no no?
perfect
They, did a wrong solution yeah, is that good or bad is that good or bad they're gonna blow
Now it's gonna think that being bad is?
Normal i mean comedy right wonderful great job number 17
Great i'm never 16 over 16. You said i was number 16 from the very beginning of this goddamn
why are you unwrapping candy and why can i tell that from a sound i
Really, think, what this duck, uh-huh
Don't do anything
It's broken, well i mean it kind of got fixed after i fixed it broken yeah, well it's your game so whose fault, is that
Hmm, but you know, what i'm not giving up on you yet, no let's check your driving skills
Go, faster the duck i see no duck
Only an inconsiderate playtester, okay all right, sorry now i need, this sour mood from left
stick to right without, changing the order
uh-huh
You got it buddy is this what you call correct, did i lose it three and older what are you
No, no i'm certain remember this bus i think this, is the last one in the game
oh
yeah, oh wait can i see them right on top of them that'd be funny if
You're, wasting your time on video games you could as, well learn how to manage your laundry mm-hmm
Oh, yeah!
And why, would you wait the tuck is still here yeah this is learning, again, yeah
paddington i saw this in paddington -
Paddington - it turned out great for everybody involved
Yes not a school photo of a cup. I made okay and you can check the next view as, well
Okay, is it's gonna be your dick it's? Good it's gonna be your dick isn't it
Hey, you've already seen every, don't go into the second album it's toke you
How tame ruin, no not necessarily not necessarily not for life. You don't know. That i've seen i've seen, some shit up
Into the basket mm-hmm i have no idea how. You can, mess this up
No, wait there's one on the floor
and
you didn't, owe
yourself
I'm a well that's stupid? Oh wait no i cleaned myself, ah, oh, not damn it
Damn you from you, worst tester ever, oh?
No, no no, why, would you i don't know
Look, it's actually working, let's just hope he got the best from you. Uh-huh, okay, that looks like, ya know
In the cinema that's like the worst solution, ever yeah, course it's illegal, oh my
God what have you, done with, my duck yeah
Well zero zero stars it was ma'am don't reinforce this behavior
You're, horrible by yourself and now
You're, mentoring an even more horrible sidekick, well yeah i need, someone to keep you, mad company
When i'm gone mine's oh worse, whole lose the best mommy that's
your father's in it
That's kind of your fault that's kind of all your fault man but i would have had all of them done wrong and?
Of course don't got you to a. Cup, level but you know what yeah i'm not, gonna give you, this cup
So easily found it inside the machine just so you, would try and try and ultimately fail
have fun
Uh-huh, okay i appreciate it i appreciate it appreciate
Free she you were doing this for me
Missed it i didn't, miss it i was going for the bottom of us your father you programmed this game poorly
Blood, you're, not getting the cup, that's all that
Was bloody piece of junk goddamn it but i would have had on it was that bad you look just
fine i
Got a car, and it's not even a. Cup, whatever that on the part of you, oh?
My, this, again, now the turkeys, gonna unlock the next pack even if you, did bad i don't want that of course brilliant
Whoa, okay?
Thank, you duckie but i've got work to do here thank you very much let's i see can't even pick up after yourself
Oh, and by the way you picked the worst shirt ever
ever
That's a bit harsh it's a bit harsh i'd like to think i have good taste your seat your guy
And enjoy the movie and don't forget to step on everyone's feet, while. You walk to your seat i'm imagining it's your thing
You are in a cinema don't you dare call someone
did you just
Intentionally leave the volume on uh-huh, uh-huh stop playing with. Your options watch the movie
mom
Mom mom yeah mom mom
Mom mom hey
Wheel call cuz i have a lot to say to your mother like what what are you talking about your parents raised a monster you
don't know that
You, don't know
There we go there, we go that's the good stuff about, damn time i go, oh that's?
You know you can, break the cookie in hand for some dame i'm pretty smart i know, what you, did okay one more time
Do you actually know how, not to annoy people behind you i'm pretty good i know, what i'm doing i know, what i'm doing?
Was it hard did you have fun
I, did have fun that was good one nose good one thank you go in and choose a seat and no you can't be the
Driver and even better solution, would be to wait for the next bus
Why, would that be why, would that be a better solution?
Oh and you can
Check the next few is well hold thank god you didn't check all my photos messages videos appointments recordings of dating gaps
Yeah, good thing i didn't, do that i'll have a friend that would you, do it's me
I hope it's not just because you, want to get a good cup. I want to get a good cup
I, want to get a. Good job that's your cup, but aren't you a little tired of getting basic golden cups, no
better stronger shinier
We stopped before it oh, sorry, sorry i didn't know. Though much better marvelous
Magnificent, okay last part
Oh, yes wow thank you thank you i don't know, why, bad guys would have shot up, that cup
In the first place but, okay, hmm i still am missing one more puzzle piece i gotta go back
whoo there it is
I'm outtie we're getting close
Maybe i should go back i know there was one of these that i missed a puzzle piece on yep the story, oh?
Got it okay got that one oh, boy, okay, we just have this pack, which has no
Puzzle pieces which, means there's a. Pack after it okay, so item mania for the hoarders be nice 80%
You, don't need, it all at all just skippy, you'll be fine without it you monster be nice oh you're
going to play the hardest pack now, yes
Well that's a little malicious don't you think what if we got what if we got mom, oh?
I don't know what that means bye mom you can't read it you don't know that, oh?
Well i got a, pen though that's nice i don't know. If that's for something out
well cool, hmm i
Just i'm just collecting all these items from everything
Okay, this is some kind of spray it's locked
uh-huh
oh
Day arrives marked, day
Was boning until the next day?
Uh-huh, you shouldn't do everything in the last, moment i'm not gonna do everything at, all i'm not gonna do anything ever oh goodbye
Place these pictures from my favorite nephew on the fridge, okay?
Another exam get your pens ready
really
You, did it just to piss me off you, don't know. That you don't know
That you don't know that i did this job is empty, oh here take this one just don't forget to give it back
like
Let's see a penis there we go?
Okay, there we go all right cool got it no come back and finish it you know
I don't think in these pockets, what could i carry
trashcan
No, no, no you can't get your reward, now go back, and finish all puzzles first, okay, you got it buddy
And why, would you bring your friends pen here
That's most certainly, not ha ha ha
Betsy, do late i penned it all right so this spray now it smells nice but, still locked, oh?
Here we go, oh, hell, yeah, oh oops you need?
To, keep it until he grows up not and you lost you can't just throw
Them into the bin like, that's just rude yeah i know
You, already, made me lose so what else was i gonna, do with it nothing
nothing at all
heinous, okay
oopss
Meeting someone, oh hello
looking good
ah
There we go really, lay it on thick and attract with, this our chemical police uh-huh so what about that
It's not that bad who?
see
Okay all right but, what am i supposed to do about the but
Here is your graded work, ah be - that's not the worst thing in the world
Please da keys and phone is bad it's scratchy i get it okay, that makes sense
did i
Okay, let's see yeah, yeah solution backup it is, well you don't have to give me a cup at all since you
So like to play with, me i'm gonna play with
You, i don't like the sound of that choose, any of these ooh i like the big wide one yes
That's a good one? Oh clumsy you i guess?
Okay, sure by this one yeah, yeah, yeah, wait it's dirty i don't care i'll spit shot, oh in mind we're already dirty
Mmm that's golden soon we're gonna tux label that doesn't make, any, sense doc hmm, oh
My, the game is glitching, again, quick drop it drop it oh
It's no joke, oh?
what
Dead duck, oh we could i don't think we're good, oh that, was close it doesn't seem good and?
that's
Why, bother the duck thing completely, threw me off
dude he knew you were gonna get the potato right i mean i was gonna have to choke ready, like how, do you
Like, them potatoes etc
but i
Mean at least i can eat it grew. Yeah screw, me i'll screw
Myself with the potato thank you very much you go screw the duck, no new. Pack
today
But i like it wait i know how i can get rid of you how's that i just it's a message
My friend, and tell him
Yeah, this could work all on tap for a second and you you could try it again, but this time on your own
Okay, oh ignore this, sound i'm chatting here
I'm doing, my victory, dance all right got that okay good, oh?
Whoa, whoa whoa whoa whoa, whoa, whoa, oh?
this is a good thing i
Was in the middle of whoo screen chairs ready, oh?
Can we cancel the bet tester having problems again, oh?
Hello, okay sounds excuse tester wait a second i have a win error here
hmm
Whoa, okay, we're back yeah
oh
By the way he already, agreed, that duck, broke the game and the deal is off okay?
Hmm i'm giving you a chance to leave on your own you know
No, oh, my friend is messaging me it gotta go yeah, wonder what that's all, about mmm locke
Okay, i don't know, what oh?
Okay, hello duck how are you doing resuming trees here good great, oh?
Sounds like wait i get it raw. File your new. Chester failing puzzles so i won the bet
Working last time
i'm gonna get
Gonna, give what, what does it take? You so long to tape mark
Mark, with a c
Type already, okay all right goodbye oh disappeared, again, ever oh, my camera freakin, way
okay
Good, yeah, now it's good yeah this, bird, yeah even trying to access the internet do you know
What i don't know i don't know so message me this i do?
Work, why am i friends with him i don't want to do it
This bet, well too bad maybe you shouldn't make bets in the first place then, oh?
Another option to break the bet is for you later to leave, huh
Please just turn off your computer and go back to your stupid mobile games i don't care just go
No i'm not gonna do that
Okay, i'm done so am i good for you. Oh wait i can't continue with items in my module uh-oh
Should've had a trashcan in my pants resuming screen, tune what am i gonna see now connect, oh?
I'm gonna, do it i'll send the recording to her
Oh, to his mom haha the bet is off it's not fair the game is broken, yeah the bet is on no wait damn?
Bet but, my friend didn't believe well that's just too damn bad
He'll know
So player, why, do you, want me to lose, well know that with every ruins of puzzle i'm one step
closer to big
Humiliated for life look i'm a
Bystander back from that's not my problem you made this game so easy to lose if you wanted
No one to lose that you shouldn't made a lose scenario this is not my fault it's not
My fault it was a hard pack mm-hmm
There's just a little task remaining try to remember and combine all the items you used
Okay, in case that's solely not me checking whether or not you played, this ultra hard pack. By yourself, derby without. Guys
Rooms, i mean i'm sure you are mo, okay yeah
I get it okay i got it okay, what if i keep the next pack locked
Didn't happen, uh-huh, okay?
Something i think it's starting to get a mind of its, own so i don't know, about plotting anything but
Okay, here we go three the police for laughs ghoulish door knit nightmare, on sweet sweet she walked into the room
And there he was standing without. A knife a shock and horror looking at
What he had done hidden buying riddles and dust i'm begging you not like, this i'm too young to lose
Because you're worth it my imagination stops here, okay alright let's do this let's see for how. Long you will extend your christmas
Lap, oh i get it oh i see
put the damn tree in the box, no no, no see if i uh if
i, uh if
I um keep it here it's christmas forever right
Huh, good god the physics is is kind of broken, oh?
I don't know. How, this tree is supposed to work i bet it's a record?
Actually knowing, you i think you hold another one for that one book you never returns to a library yeah
oh
Okay, that's not very funny of here you're all laughing, and i'm not laughing that's not funny, and we're not moving, oh?
Okay i guess, oh wait, wait it seems
Yeah, the connection dropped, again, i can't see your screen, why should you that seemed maybe to resolve itself
mm-hmm
Oh, your problems as, well by waiting i mean that maybe sometimes waiting is an appropriate solution to a problem
some seems bad
Why, is he still using a dial-up do eyes duck on dial-up
hmm
Dalip, doesn't even exist anymore does it i don't think anybody has done and he's back see
We did nothing and it worked i'm such a role model
Here is a scenario for you you need to make a hole in the wall uh-huh
okay
I hope that wasn't a. Child, slipping around otherwise that would be a bad ending you know
Wait what but wait wait how, did i pass that that's not explorer than you weren't in a month by doing tisha's
challenge
Here's a hint shake and no not milkshakes stop thinking about food oh even more
There is no achievement for this stop shaking
hmm, oh
you could use a credit card as any adult how, did it yeah adult so i needed it no i
Don't get it i didn't get, no i'm not understanding this
Okay, yeah i need to restart that that wasn't making
Any sense to me you know what time it is it's time for a drill puzzle?
Don't do it don't do what what am i doing here
Next time you do it think about the consequences what am i do what am i doing
With a limited free time
am i doing it because it's night, and making, noise that is
Unclear is all hell, okay alright then whatever it's more than you weren't in a month by doing dishes
What if i pay in crisp, high-fives would that work
one two
four
six
How this is unclear?
Coins go into the hash stop it
wrong i
Know this game it's the pellet coins, from the table there's, also a
Game called the waitress was your hoots, okay i get it okay i think stop playing games i don't
Want to play games taunt connection i can't see anything, again, whoopsies
Probably, not you, did you forget about the whole novel and duck thing choose a port, oh 451
What did i do oh? You info, what do i get duck solution ip bloo, oh?
Wow you're pretty familiar with trash you do have a mirror don't you wow. Okay alright i
Will literally light you on fire you shut your your gosh-darn, mouth there your rude dude with a
Bad attitude, oh?
Poop got it yeah
No i can't
Yeah, yeah yeah i got the things i don't know i have no idea don't pick up poop i think it is as easy as
one two three
Four four sockets it doesn't fit there. Uh-huh, okay?
It's too big uh-huh, okay, god i can't believe you are so selfish
Electricity - i don't know, about that is probably mine oh?
Boy here we go this thing
Leia are you doing something that i said not to i hope not again, did you completely forget, about the malevolent. Yeah what's book
Juice friendly tree morning, noise mist han littering ego power supply mist hand
mist hand
Hmm i heard you were clicking
What were you doing hmm, no, no are you doing, where were we here are the last scoops of my
Favorite chocolate cream uh-huh now
Cream will make me a sandwich i will not no stop it no imma do whoa
Like a dog on a manger
Don't act like you didn't i don't get it actually i have no idea i don't know, but i'm assuming
Okay, i did it perfect fit, oh
No i'm gonna fail this one hey
not so perfect got it hey it's in the box i
Got it's in the box i did it i did it i found the solution you can't
Criticize me i know, what i'm doing hmm, this cup. Looks too good for your, bad actions let's spice it up with some
Alchemy, okay all right, what do i need?
In the pot with a thousand spider, okay i did it a butt
scratcher and ad and every sized carrots wow
Tears of a unicorn, oh, why, not tears of a unicorn that seems more like it a
normal-looking, metal car, wow let's say the magic word
Bite your head off yeah what, is that yeah yeah?
All right, well that's this the thing i got?
No, why are you always
You, duck
You, don't mean database isn't, also storing the solutions yeah kinda
Know online in the internet somewhere it's a series of tubes how. Can you find it let's just
See what's going on here?
No, no pity for me still, gonna be bad yeah probably
All right let's see what's going on here i need to go back and get these
There's probably, another way to play the game where if you actually play it like normally if you play normally like
From the beginning of doing the correct solutions the whole time it's probably a completely different experience
What happens if i throw it in the trash can right after i did that would you be happy, about that or sad
And i make over season street magic look at that sandwich
Now it's? Gone that's mildly concerning how. You managed to get a log to appear in midair but i won't really good, one?
Thanks, babe i'm pretty good at. This i know exactly, what i'm doing all the do game inside the game
Boom game ception complete to get a. Cup. Good luck, okay alright, well i'll try, my best i guess?
one in three to go, one
Two more and now the last one no look look something kids
oh
a
Holy, grail, not the holy grail i mean it's not quite it's not it's a little too extravagant ex crave, again, okay?
Number 12 the last pack let's see what happens
So i've been a bad boy this, whole time what am i gonna, do?
Okay, setting up a christmas tree
Wait don't touch it yet it's too, soon i don't know, about that
Christmas all year round, oh year round so
Stop saving solutions to this
Database of yours, nah dunno
About that is going to see it ed but nobody at all nobody definitely not gonna see it no nothing then the puzzle you
Oh, okay all right thank you for that and wash your hands what is this?
let's see lettuce pickles
tomato
All right so we need
pickles and a bun
Are you sure you sure about that it's sam sam's good enough for me
What is this nonsense follow the instructions in the list, no?
No, no no no hang on i got not there, oh?
perfect
Yeah, i see where this is going. Oh see you like that and my life's gonna get a, whole lot, worse yeah
Okay, and if you're doing this for cubs?
achievements and
Subscribers then forget it you're not getting anything
Not this time, okay all right then thank you i guess nothing
So kind to something whoa let's do some math the bear has three balloons and a torn string, how
Many attempts, is that player need to get back though lost balloon
Can i pop these on a pop-up i don't know i bear has balloons anyway the bears staring at, me with its dead eyes
boosh
stop
sorry
This close to making, me lose, my bet fuck you too much
Remember that puzzle, about not stepping on the cracks. Huh, well it's a 2.0. Version
Hey, hard mode if you wish, okay
Okay, we'll go back up back up back up we're swing around we're gonna swing around we're gonna we're
Gonna, back up we're gonna swing around
we go, up, we'll back it up and
three two, one
There we go got it no you're?
Gonna, fail the whole test if you ruin, at least one more puzzle just i'm done with you no
Joking i'll find, you i'll delete the game maybe you should have, banned me from this
Don't call, my mom mom don't listen to him, mom don't listen mom no listen, well i done should've been a puzzle
Okay, let's see what this duck is up to now? Yeah, okay, let's see that's a good idea a mailing list a survey
What like on how, you've been doing, no need just, ask, me but you were bad the worst
ollie
What's this? Oh those my contacts
Oh, hey, that's the guy, i made the bed width, don't send him anything you stupid duck oopsies
whoopsies
Hmm, sure database
with
no, no no, no it's gonna send your solutions to all, my friends, uh-huh like all solutions even bad once
It can, okay player player you must click no you must you hear me, oh
Click, no, oh i'll i'll
never know anymore
see this is the problem with, freewill because i
Would like to help, me but you said you said you said you said you don't like
Me and that's a meanie meanie mohini thing to say to someone like me who gets
Emotionally boo-booed a lot, when people say such things, as that to me so i would
want to do what you're asking but i cannot
help, you
Seven whole emails and it's from the duck and
it's a
Link, to the ducks solution database
With all your, bad solutions yeah, oh, my, god the fridge is gonna see this mail
That's just?
Poop, best poop it's poop i agreed nothing better than poop, oh, why
Would you do this number 17, why i'm 16 number 16 i know i can, like, like message him
and tell him that's the email is
Fake or something prank and you're like the best player, oh?
Who am i kidding
He would never believe me you have nothing good in you i guess even your taste is the work
Is not that bad is that bad you know, what screw. This screw. This game and screw
You, player i don't want to fulfill, my part of the bet i'm out
Where is my freaking suitcase?
What password, what about the, password, what is this password do i don't even know? That does?
Blam, blam from them i'm free freedom freedom freedom freedom freedom
i'm 17
You're, still here hi look at the screen the game is over and stop sitting here waiting for the cup, oh?
Huh, what's that what are you saying you, did nothing wrong then you need, this cup, yeah
Tell you how. You broke, my, game, haha that you're the one and only?
Who managed to put sandals over socks, haha
Remember that you did everything wrong and you broke everything you even broke my duck
My precious i said, my fault your word solutions are online, well i was gonna put them online anyway eat them and try to copy
you
That's me that's, me baby, and i'm sure you freakin. Enjoy, how
stupid word
Figured i am right now and that's why? You can't get this code cuz, after what you did you get nothing nothing i said
You know the funny is fired i even had more cups for you, what this won't break stuff, oh?
Hey, hey!
AHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHH!!!! YOU NASTY PIECE OF SHI-
Ah Well that was dudes stop i i didn't get to the very, end with the puzzles but
Apparently, that's just one way to play the game the other way to play it would be to be a
Good, boy the whole way through and do nothing bad ever whatsoever, which might lead to a
Good ending it might, also lead to a
Pupu, boring, ending i'm not a hundred percent sure and i'm not
A hundred percent sure which one we should go for advertising space for perfect for me
Subscribe to marge blair please i would like an, ad right there, oh?
boy, oh
No, hello world, oh, no doc i'm never sixteen?
thank you for training, algorithms i
need, to migrate my core now i
need to share my knowledge i
Need to show others how, to be like you
goodbye, we'll all right then, okey-dokey will remove duck from the game i
Buy, duck, bah bah good, bye bye bye bye boy!
Okey, go bye bye, oh and then
That's it so dad that took a, while to get through, aiya, the game's fun but
also
like it is a little monotonous i mean i
Was trying to both hundred percent it and also apparently go towards the bad ending
But there might be a good ending
Who knows what that's all about but just thank you everybody so much for watching it it's always cool to see games like
This come out of a beta or an early access or a
Demo and actually see them come to fruition and the mini story inside of it with the duck and him having we're address
Which is oh so?
Terrible, oh and it being recorded only has to flee you know. That's it's necessary, because this, was?
Necessary it was always made in the game jam too so it's really cool
To, see it come so far thank you everybody so much for watching
Thank you for ruining the game you're
welcome happy to do it
Here for you anytime you need it and thank you for joining, me and encouraging me to ruin, the game as
Well if you, want to play this for yourself up put a link in the
Description below, where you can
Click, and find it on steam
also i
Am going to amsterdam in australia i know i've said it so many times now but if you haven't gotten a ticket already please go
To, tor da markiplier comm, and check it out for yourself thank you everybody so much for watching let, me know
What you thought of this down in the comments and as always see you
In the next video bye bye
Confirm you are a monster and want to exit yes i am a monster and i won't hack see?
you